-No matter who the Mayor
of New York is, we hate him,
and then, by the time he goes,
we're like,
"That's the mayor.
We love him," you know.
Like Bloomberg, we hated.
He'd be on --
He'd come out and like cover
the city in beige carpeting,
and then, be like,
"Shoes off."
And we'd be like, "Ah!"
And then, by the time he left,
we were like,
"Hey, it's Mayor Bloomberg."
And now we hate him again.
It's a cycle.
♪♪
-Congrats on everything,
I got to say.
-Thank you, man.
Thanks so much for having me.
-I'm so excited.
I'm looking forward to the show.
Now, I know you -- I know
your stand-up pretty well.
When did you start
doing stand-up?
-I started doing stand-up
when I was about 19 years old,
and I started in New York
but then
I went on the road right away
just 'cause those actually pay.
'Cause shows in New York's
like nine people,
and eight of them are comics.
And one of them's, like,
a pile of clothes,
so I went on the road
to do shows right away.
Like, I was doing --
I remember in my early 20s,
I was doing a show
in Murfreesboro, Tennessee.
Murfreesboro.
I'm pronouncing it correctly.
-Okay, okay.
-I'm not mispronouncing it.
-You're not -- no.
-That's how it's pronounced.
-That's a place.
-Murfreesboro.
It was -- I think it was named
by a dying Confederate general
as he barely sat up in bed
eating mashed potatoes,
and his grandson was like,
"Pappy,
you got to name the town!"
And he was like,
[Slurring] "Murfreesboro."
[ Laughter ]
They're like,
"Put it on the sign!"
[ Applause ]
-It is an odd name.
-There's about nine R's
in "Murfreesboro."
But I was doing stand-up.
This is one of the worst shows
I ever had.
I was doing stand-up comedy in
Murfreesboro, Tennessee,
at an outdoor campground
next to a beer truck.
-Oh!
This sounds awful.
-Well, later, some would allege
that I was blocking
the beer truck.
[ Laughter ]
And I disagree with them.
-[ Laughs ]
-I was doing the show
on purpose --
I was doing the show on purpose.
-Of course you were.
-And it sounds awful,
but it wasn't a mistake.
-It was a gig.
-Yeah, it wasn't like
I was driving across the south
in an old jalopy
and it broke down,
and the people in Murfreesboro
were like,
"We'll give you supper,
but you got to make funnies
for us tonight." Like...
I meant to do it.
I had it on my calendar.
I was like, "Oh, boy, oh, boy,
only two more weeks until the
worst night in my entire life."
[ Laughter ]
-But they didn't appreciate you?
-Well, no! I got to the show.
And I put "show" in many quotes.
[ Laughter ]
-How many quotes?
-Just as many quotes as there
are R's in "Murfreesboro."
[ Laughter ]
Take all the R's
and make them quotes.
I get out on the stage,
and the stage was really nice.
It was a lot like this,
except not at all.
It was a couple 2x4s
lying in dirt.
I start to perform
stand-up comedy, okay?
And one guy yelled from the back
what is the best heckle
I've heard in my life.
He yelled, [Southern accent]
"Excuse me, sir.
I think
I speak for everyone here
when I say
that we would enjoy silence
more than
the sound of your voice."
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-Yes.
Insanely mean, no?
But also, how very eloquent.
-That is
the most eloquent heckle
I've ever heard in my life.
-It's a beautiful
turn of phrase,
to enjoy silence more
than the sound of your voice.
If that was, like, the last line
of a Maya Angelou poem,
you would just shut the book
and look out the window.
[ Laughter ]
-Here you are -- you're hosting
"Saturday Night Live" this week
for the second time.
-Second time, which is great.
I was nervous. Some people
don't get to come back.
-That's true.
They do controversial things,
like they tear up
a picture of the pope
or they are Robert Blake.
And they don't get to --
[ Laughter ]
They don't get to be
on the show again.
[ Laughter ]
-"They are Robert Blake."
-They are Robert Blake,
the person.
-No, exactly.
But I mean, you should be
kind of used to it.
You were a writer on
"Saturday Night Live" in 2009,
I want to say.
-Yeah, from like '08 to 2012,
I was a writer there.
And -- well, it's totally
different, though, now,
because I'm on camera,
whereas before,
I was like a busboy and now,
I'm the maitre D.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but did you ever think
that you would host?
-No, I mean, I auditioned to be
on the show,
but I was hired as a writer,
because I was auditioning
and I remember they went "No."
[ Laughter ]
But then, I would get on camera
occasionally.
But the idea of hosting
is totally surreal.
-Well, it's a great cast.
I mean, you're gonna be --
you're in good hands.
-It's really been the most fun.
-Do you remember the first time
you were ever in a sketch, ever?
-Yeah, I was in -- it wasn't on
"Update" or anything.
I was just like
a clipboard operator, you know,
when they go like, "Take five."
-I've done that.
-Yeah.
I was in an Activia yogurt
commercial sketch
with Kristen Wiig
and Jason Sudeikis.
-Oh, and she was
Jamie Lee Curtis.
-She was Jamie Lee Curtis.
And Activia yogurt allegedly
gave you diarrhea at the time.
I think was the premise.
[ Laughter ]
And I come in,
I go, like, "Take one."
And I snapped it, then I walked
off camera, you know.
They go, like,
"This way, this way."
And then Bobby Moynihan
was there,
and it was my first time
on camera,
so we start high-fiving,
like a lot.
Like way too much for one line.
-Yeah, but he was so psyched
for you.
-And then, I look over
and Lorne is staring at us.
Like this, and I'm just
high-fiving him, and I see him.
And then, I realize that I'm
late and I've missed my cue.
And I ran back on and was like,
"Take five."
And, like, it was a full lull.
I thought no one caught it.
I get to the after party, and
our mutual friend Neal Brennan
comes over to me and he goes,
"Hey, man, great job.
You were five seconds late
on that second cue."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, people can see it,
I mean --
-Oh, it was -- yeah.
-But I mean, I don't know
if you guys remember,
but we actually have a clip.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Here's John Mulaney
missing his cue
in his first-ever
"Saturday Night Live" sketch.
Check it.
-I killed this Activia.
Can I get another one?
-Yeah, of course, yeah.
Here you go.
-Thank you.
-I'll take one for myself.
I'll keep going here.
All right,
let's do this. Here we go.
-Activia testimonial number two.
-Oh, my God. You were a bit --
Neal Brennan
is almost exactly right.
-Yeah.
Wait, I was remarkably calm.
-Yeah, you were.
-I was like,
"I don't know, take two."
I was high-fiving. I'm sorry.
-You were just jumping up
and down with Bobby Moynihan.
-Yeah, yeah.
-You're gonna crush it
this weekend.
We love you, buddy.
-Thank you, buddy.
Thank you for having me.
-Please, John Mulaney,
everybody.
-There was a thing saying
you might run for mayor.
-For New York.
No, New York, not South Bend.
-No, for mayor of New York City?
-Yeah, I know,
I'm going to
start with New York.
Listen, no.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's not --
Thank you, I appreciate that.
-Standing ovation.
-Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
[ Cheering continues ]
-Please.
-They were ready for it.
It's unbelievable.
-Thank you.
Please, sit down.
Please sit down.
-Here he is.
-Please sit.
-John Mulaney!
-Please.
-Mayor Mulaney!
-Earlier this evening,
I called Mayor de Blasio
and I conceded because I got
zero votes, and --
[ Laughter ]
No, I don't know why I got this
in my head.
I know why.
I had, like, too much --
I had like a month
where I wasn't doing anything.
-Yeah.
-So...
I was walking around New York.
I was getting so angry about
things.
You know, there was --
so I said --
I came home and I said,
"I'm going to run for mayor,"
to my wife, you know?
-Yeah.
-And she said, "Okay, but you
have to think about stuff
for all five boroughs.
It can't just be
things on our block."
And I was like, "All right."
But then, I just -- look.
No matter who the Mayor
of New York is, we hate him,
and then, by the time he goes,
we're like,
"That's the mayor.
We love him," you know.
Like Bloomberg, we hated.
He'd be on --
He'd come out and like cover
the city in beige carpeting,
and then, be like, "Shoes off."
And we'd be like, "Ah!"
And then, by the time he left,
we were like,
"Hey, it's Mayor Bloomberg."
And now we hate him again.
It's a cycle.
-Yeah.
-So de Blasio is low, right?
-Remember --
Were you at the Paul Simon
concert when de Blasio got up?
-Yeah, we were there together.
-Yeah.
Remember, they're like,
"Ladies and gentlemen,
Mayor de Blasio."
"Boo!"
[ Laughter ]
-It was louder than like
an encore for like "Graceland."
-Yeah.
-They're like, "Whoo!"
-It was like Vince McMahon
level theater.
Like, "Boo!"
-Yeah, that was crazy.
-De Blasio walks out with his
stupid sideburns and --
[ Laughter ]
But -- But I -- here's --
Okay. Here's --
Look, I know I won't be good
as mayor.
Okay? I know that.
But here's my thing.
I'm going to get rid
of Uber and Lyft,
and if you don't like it,
you can get rid of me
in two years.
[ Laughter ]
But you can't --
There's a bus lane,
and then there's a bike lane,
and then there's
one million new Ubers,
10 billion new Lyfts.
-Yeah.
-And it's just you can't do it.
And I have a whole commercial
laid out.
-Really?
-Yeah.
I mean, I haven't shot it,
but you know,
you can imagine it.
You can imagine it.
I'm imagining it.
So here's the commercial.
All right.
It's not fun, but it's --
this is just a good idea.
[ Laughter ]
So it's an ambulance --
Shh, this is serious.
So it's an ambulance,
and it's going
up Sixth Avenue at 3:00 P.M.
It's an ambulance.
Sirens are going, you know?
You feel the tension, right?
-What time of the day?
-3:00 P.M.
-Yeah.
It goes, it's 3:00 P.M.
It's not rush hour.
It's not lunchtime.
And the streets are jammed.
And then I'll have an actor
that looks like de Blasio
ride by on a bicycle, right?
[ Laughter ]
And then it'll say,
"Now imagine someone you love
is in this ambulance."
And then it goes, "boom."
And it says, "Bill de Blasio
said he'd fix everything
in New York," which he didn't.
He didn't say that.
But...
[ Laughter ]
-You can't put words
in his mouth.
-Oh, you can do that.
-You can't do that.
-I'm not going to put "quotes."
I'll say --
I'll say he said something
like -- okay.
Bill de Blasio was like,
"I'm going to
fix everything in New York,"
right?
-You're safe.
-I'm in safe territory.
-My lawyer says you're safe.
My lawyer says you're safe,
yeah.
-Good, yeah.
And then it will just say,
"John Mulaney as Mayor."
-Wow, that's pretty good.
-I think when you say -- yeah.
-That's a good, that's a...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...memorable commercial.
And it hits a nerve.
-I think it's, like,
mean-spirited.
I don't like that I thought of
it, but once I thought of it,
I thought, like,
"That's a good idea."
I -- I like Mayor de Blasio.
I have had run-ins with him
that I found awkward.
I was hosting that Museum
of Natural History benefit
that Mr. Lorne Michaels does.
-Our boss.
-Yeah.
The producer of
"Saturday Night Live."
-And "The Tonight Show"
as well.
-And "The Tonight Show," yeah,
-That's right.
He's our producer.
He produces everything
in this building.
-Yeah, that's right, yeah.
He's a good TV producer.
-He's fantastic.
-Yeah, he's got hits.
So he has this benefit
at the Natural History museum.
Have you ever hosted it,
where you kind of go,
"Welcome, everybody."
-Of course.
-"This is --
Look at all the animals."
Because it's like the zoo,
but they're dead, you know.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a museum.
Yeah, it's a museum.
-It's a museum
of animal bodies
and what they would look like
next to fake trees and stuff.
But it's a nice museum.
It's a great place.
So I had --
I worked all day --
I worked for like three days
on all these jokes,
and most of them
were de Blasio jokes.
-Yeah.
-Because it's a New York
audience, and I, you know,
I mean, I opened --
I opened bad right away
because I was like,
"This is great.
I saw there's an elephant here.
So finally for one night,
the elephant in the room for you
guys is not Jeffrey Epstein,"
and -- yeah, right.
[ Audience ohs ]
Just like you.
Hey, no, but just like you,
they were upset right away.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah.
-And I said, but --
[ Laughter ]
-It's a tough room.
-"But like Jeffrey Epstein,
this elephant was murdered."
I did a second part of the joke.
[ Audience ohs ]
I know, right. Just --
Yeah, exactly.
-But it's also --
But this is a good room.
That room, I will say,
is a little tough.
-You mean the museum with
the highest ceiling in the world
and all the richest people
in the world
staring at you?
It looks like an event the Joker
would crash into it.
[ Laughter ]
And...
-You should have opened
with that.
You should have opened
with that one.
with that.
-Wait, I got to get
another chance.
So then, I just did these
introductory remarks,
two of which you just heard,
which were terrible jokes.
So I sit down at the table,
and then, someone runs up
and says, "Ladies and gentlemen,
we have a special guest here.
Mayor Bill de Blasio has
dropped by the benefit."
Now, this was called
a black tie event.
Now that means that you wear
a tuxedo if you're a man.
Now I'm not saying --
You're not a good per--
I'm not saying you're a better
person if you're in a tuxedo,
but Bill de Blasio walks up
in a light-blue suit
with a bright-red tie,
like a clown.
And...
[ Laughter ]
And they go, "Bill de Blasio."
And this is a nice event,
and people go, "Boo!"
And I hear one person go,
"Hiss!"
-Wow.
Wow. Bringing back the hiss.
-So then, Mayor de Blasio
gets up.
And no, he was not invited.
He had just left his
presidential campaign
because he heard it was a lock
and he didn't want the
pressure to get to him.
So...
[ Laughter ]
He gets up, and he's like,
"Hi, it's me, the mayor."
You know, he had to remind
everyone when he was mayor
because he had run
for president.
He's like, "I'm the mayor,
this is a great museum
because they allow anyone
in here.
Anyone of any
sexual orientation."
And everyone was like,
"Yeah, that's every museum.
Like, there's..."
[ Laughter ]
The only barrier to entry is
a suggested donation,
which no one does.
No one's keeping anyone
out of a museum.
-No.
-So then he said --
So I, by the way, have
in my pocket a page of jokes
that are all about de Blasio.
My next seven minutes was just
going to be de Blasio jokes.
So then de Blasio says --
and it's all --
"This event is run by
the great Lorne Michaels,
an important person in New York,
even though he's not
from New York."
And I was like, "Oh, man."
[ Hissing ]
Like, okay, yeah, right?
-Getting hisses right now.
-Getting hissed.
-Someone's hissing over there.
-So I get back --
So I turn to Lorne and I go,
"I have a page
of de Blasio jokes."
And Lorne goes, "Do them."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Dude.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That New York thing --
that New York thing,
like, when he said that,
I was like, "Oh!"
And I know Lorne is from Canada.
I know it.
And he talks about it. He'll go,
"I'm from Canada," you know?
But if he looked me
in the eye and he went,
"I'm from New York, right?"
I'd be like,
"Yeah, yeah,
you're from New York."
-He's one of the most
New York people
of all time.
-I know.
-Welcome back.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
-Thank you for being here.
Congrats on this movie,
by the way.
"Spider-Man:
Into the Spider-Verse."
I've never seen an animated film
like this ever in my lifetime.
It blew me away.
-It's an absolutely
mind-blowing animated film.
It, like, combines different
types of animation
'cause it's bringing together
all these different universes
of different spider-men, women,
and pigs in my case.
-Now you play -- which I kind of
remember a little bit but --
-Do you remember the character?
-I kind of a little bit, maybe.
I don't know.
But there was a character.
It was all
different types of spider-men,
but you play Spider-Ham.
[ Laughter ]
Spider-Ham is Peter Porker.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And was this, like,
a short-lived comic book?
-Oh, no.
No, no, not short-lived.
[ Laughter ]
It was -- it was a spin-off
of sorts.
I think started in 1983,
and there are die-hard
Spider-Ham fans out there.
-Honestly, this is
such a cool thing.
I'm going in,
and I don't really know much
about comic books or Spider-Man.
I know of them.
-Well, I knew nothing about
the actual project
when I first started recording.
-About the project?
-Oh, yeah.
So, I got a call,
and I said, "Hello." You know.
[ Laughter ]
-Good for you, though.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Good improvising already.
-Absolutely.
Nothing fancy, ordinary hello,
right?
-No, great, hello, yeah.
-And they said,
"This is a company, big company.
Do you want to be in a movie?
And we can't tell you
anything about it
and we can't send you a script."
Because when it's
these superhero things,
they really keep them
under wraps.
So, they said, "We can't tell
you anything about it.
We can't send you a script."
Which is how a lot of
kidnappings begin.
[ Laughter ]
But I was available, so...
-I'm up for an adventure.
Let's go for it.
-I was like, "All right.
Yeah, sure. What time? Where?"
-Unmarked van.
-Yeah, okay.
-Sure. Sounds cool.
[ Laughter ]
-Cool. Blindfold? Fine.
So, I get to a building and,
you know, it's like Los Angeles.
So it's not like a famous --
It's just a slab of concrete.
And I go in, and Rodney Rothman
was there,
and he said, "Do you know
what's about to happen?"
Which if it was a kidnapping is
a super creepy way to begin.
[ Laughter ]
-That's even worse.
"Do you know
what's about to happen?"
-Yeah. These psychological games
are like, "Are you prepared?"
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-"For level two?"
So, they said,
"We're making this film."
They explained it.
They said that the cast
was insane.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Nicolas Cage, Hailee Steinfeld,
Mahershala Ali.
-Mahershala Ali is unbelievable.
-And Jake Johnson.
I mean, it's, like,
a great group of people.
I said,
"Who else are the actors in it?"
And they said, "You."
And I said, "I'm scared because
I've never been like --
I've never not known
what a movie is
and then I'm about to be
in the movie."
-Yeah, and then be in a scene
with Nicolas Cage.
-Yeah, and they said,
"Well, you play a superhero
who is a pig who makes --"
[ Laughter ]
"Who makes
nonstop outdated jokes."
And I said, "I got it."
[ Laughter ]
-"Yeah, I got this nailed."
-Absolutely nailed it.
It's really fun, and, like,
I know this sounds like,
I'm selling it,
but I kind of am, but --
-Yeah, that's why you're here,
I guess.
-Yeah, I guess that is why
we're really here in some way.
-Yeah, me too. Yeah.
-But it's like --
like, adults will like it
and children will like it,
and I only note that
because when I was a kid,
there was no movies
that were for kids.
There'd be like one a year.
-Yeah.
-They do like "The Little
Mermaid" once a year.
And the rest of the time it was
like parents would be like,
"You're going to the movies."
You'd be like,
"What are we seeing?
They'll be like, "Working Girl."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Just cover your eyes
the whole time."
[ Laughter ]
-Your parents would take you to,
like, those adult dramas?
-Yeah, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-No, for real, they did.
I remember my mom
and her sisters took me,
when I was maybe 7 or something,
to see this movie
"Regarding Henry."
Remember that?
-Sure. Yeah.
-Hear the murmurs.
-Oh, yeah. Harrison Ford.
-Harrison Ford, Annette Bening,
and he's shot in the head,
and he has amnesia
and they're trying to
rebuild their marriage.
Very adult.
[ Laughter ]
-Sounds like a kid's movie.
Kids love that stuff.
-I had to pee within
the first five minutes,
and it's a very good
Mike Nichols film.
So, my mom was like,
"I really don't want to leave,
but I'll take you.
So then I come back.
10 minutes later,
I got to pee again,
and she said, "I'm not taking
you to the bathroom again.
All right?
I want to watch this movie."
So, I said, "Okay." I had to go.
I just waited and I just
went in my jeans and --
[ Audience gasps ]
I didn't mind. And then --
[ Laughter ]
I had a little, you know,
jacket, you know, kid, right?
And I tied it
around my waist in front
and I walked out, and my mom
said, "What's that about?"
And I said, "Well, you said
we couldn't get up again.
So I peed in my jeans."
-You said that?
Yeah, and she was like, "What?
Why would you do that?"
And I was like, "I don't know.
You said you wanted to
watch the movie."
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
What a good kid, man.
-Yeah.
And also, you know,
I like Mike Nichols, too.
When I'm 7, I want to see.
[ Laughter ]
I want to stick around.
-So, you go into this thing
blind and you --
they give you a script
or do you get to improvise
a little bit, or...?
-Oh. So, yes.
It is wonderfully scripted,
but they did a thing
that is very generous
when they say to comedy people.
They say, "Have fun with it and,
you know, add your own words."
And so,
for the very first session,
I'm still in fight or flight
'cause I think
it's a kidnapping.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I did go my own way with it,
and I threw in my own lines,
and what happened was I was
just cursing wildly.
[ Laughter ]
-This is you.
Thank you for -- you
saved this exclusively for us.
These are outtakes.
These are not in the film.
-Yes, they sent along the video.
-John Mulaney doing
the voice of Spider-Ham.
-This is real. I did this.
-Yeah.
-Damn right.
Ah, you bastards.
And how the [bleep]
is he gonna do that?
[ Laughter ]
And how the [bleep]
exactly is he gonna do that?
Two days.
I've been Spider-Ham
30 [bleep] years.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-They can't use any of that?
When -- At what point
did you find out --
-They were like --
they had said, "Go nuts."
So I'm like, "You mother--"
I'm screaming,
and then I paused.
I went,
"What is this movie rated?"
And they said, "PG."
And I said, "Oh, so, nothing
I've just said is usable."
And they said, "No, but we just
wanted to you have fun."
[ Laughter ]
-Your new Netflix special,
"John Mulaney &
The Sack Lunch Bunch."
-Yes.
-I'm very excited about this.
This is sort of a variety show
with kids involved.
-Yes. This is a show for kids,
by an adult, with kids present.
It's a children's
musical special,
and I am a man with no children
and no musical ability,
but I wanted
to do a variety special
and I wanted to do it with kids.
-Yeah.
-And kind of -- It's a nod to
the shows I grew up on.
-Yeah.
-And I wanted to do like the
"Sesame Street" I grew up on
and you probably grew up on,
which was that, like, funky,
like, Art Garfunkel and Grover
and a girl named Gina
would be, like, leaning against
the stoop, smoking a cigarette.
And there would be, like, music,
but then someone would come over
and be like,
"Did you hear about Mr. Hooper?"
And they'd be like, "What?"
They'd be like, "He died."
And they'd be like "Oh, no.
What's death?"
And they'd be
like, "It's when you die."
And then they'd just cut to an
industrial video of
an orange crayon being made,
and we forget about
that we just learned the
existential dread of death
and we're watching a weird
industrial of
orange wax becoming crayons.
And then you cut back,
and it's Smokey Robinson.
And he's like, "Near, far."
And then it would cut back,
and it was like, "Alright."
-Yeah, what a weird show.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-It is bizarre.
-Yeah, I don't think there was
a script to that.
-No, not at all.
You start the
whole special with a quote.
Do you mind...
-Oh, yeah.
-...reading the quote or saying
the quote to everyone?
-The special begins
with a maxim that I find
to be quite true, which is, "Do
you know who tells the truth?"
"Drunks and children."
-Yeah, that's --
-Yeah.
-And -- Yeah.
Whose --
[ Cheers and applause ]
They agree.
-It's true.
-They agree.
-Wise words. Wise words.
-Who is that quote from?
-That is from Erika Jayne of
"Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills" --
Season 9, Episode 20.
It's right after they go to
the wine-tasting thing
where Kyle and Teddi
get way too drunk.
The next day, Erika says,
"You know who tells the truth?
Drunks and children."
I was working on
the special at the time
and I was in one of those
moods where I went,
"That's going in."
-Yeah. Absolutely.
-And kids are kind of --
They're not like drunks.
Well, they can't drive.
They shouldn't drive.
But they are very blunt
and truthful,
the way some people are after
they've had a few drinks.
-Yeah.
-They've come up to me on set.
One kid came up to me the first
day and he said --
'Cause the special was directed
by a great director,
Rhys Thomas, who
I've worked with many times.
And he said,
"So, you're not the director?"
And I said, "No."
And he said, "Oh."
And I said, "Do you think I have
less authority now?"
And the kid said, "Yeah, I do."
And he walked away.
-Just honest.
-Yeah, just blunt.
-But you talk about,
like, some --
-They got into their fears.
Yeah.
I wanted to know what
they were worried about.
-What scared you as a child,
John Mulaney?
Little John Mulaney.
-What scared me as a child
was not just Robert De Niro
from "Cape Fear"
breaking into my house,
but it was that I,
being the only one
that was prepared for
Robert De Niro from "Cape Fear"
to break into our house, that I
would be the lone survivor.
And so it was on me --
It was my burden,
because of none -- My brother,
my sisters, my stupid parents --
they weren't prepared for
Robert De Niro.
And he kicked
the crap out of Nick Nolte,
and, Dad, you are no Nick Nolte.
-Alright, alright.
-So I had to sleep with --
I slept with a crowbar
under my bed.
-What?!
-Yeah, yeah.
I just found it recently.
It was kind of sweet.
And...
-It became like a toy of yours?
-No. It became a crowbar,
'cause I was ready
to roll at any time.
And I had a bat,
and it was like,
"If I hear
Robert De Niro downstairs
ha-ha-ha-ing it, you know --
-Yeah. You were ready to attack.
-Yeah.
-I got to say,
the celebrity cameos
are fantastic
in this special, as well.
-Yes, yes.
-It's, like, Richard Kind...
Yes. Jake Gyllenhaal.
-Jake Gyllenhaal is in this.
David Byrne.
-Yes,
David Byrne, André De Shields,
who just won the Tony from
"Hadestown,"
and Annaleigh Ashford.
A lot of great Broadway
and film people
came together,
which was super fun.
-Is there any guests that
you wanted have on
that you couldn't get?
-Stevie Nicks.
-Ooh.
-I wanted Stevie Nicks.
-She's tough.
-A hush fell over the room
unlike any
I've ever heard before.
-Yeah, 'cause she's
a magical being.
-She is a magical being,
but she --
When she passes on a TV project,
she really passes on it.
-What do you mean?
-Well, I was looking for her
for like a month.
You know, I can't catch her.
You know, she's a ghost
in the wind, right?
-Yeah.
-So, I finally called
her manager
and I said,
"This is John Mulaney."
And she went,
"Oh, you're that guy."
And I went, "Yes, I am."
And she said, "Listen,
Stevie heard about the project,
but she's on tour
and she has a limited break,
and so it's just not
something she can do."
I said, "I totally understand.
Thank you so much for
considering it."
And then she continued.
She said, "Also,
Stevie listened to the song,
and she doesn't think
it's funny."
And I said, "Oh, okay.
Yeah, you know, the first answer
was good enough."
And she said,
"Stevie's confused,
because this is not
one of her songs."
And I said, "Oh, no, I know.
It's a parody song that she
would be singing in.
But if she doesn't like it
and is not available --"
And she said, "Yeah,
she doesn't like it."
And I said, "Okay."
And I started
laughing really hard,
because this was the longest
pass I'd ever heard,
in about a decade of
entertainment.
And she said, "You know, she did
do TV once with Ryan Murphy."
I said, "Yeah, she was on
'American Horror Story: Coven.'
She did 'Seven Wonders,'
that song."
And she said,
"Yes, but 'Seven Wonders'
is one of Stevie's songs."
And I said, "I know that.
This was a parody song."
And she said,
"But she doesn't find it funny."
And I said, "I get that.
I get all of it."
-Oh, my God! Wow!
-I said, "I want to say --
I want to let you know --"
I said to her,
"I've been passed on many times.
This is the greatest pass
in my career,
and please thank Stevie for me
and just tell her I said 'hello'
and basically tell her I wrote
the part because
I want to hang out with her."
And her manager said,
"Well, then come hang out.
We have people in
the backyard all the time."
-So, are you going to hang out
with Stevie Nicks?
-I don't know.
She didn't like my song.
-Come on, man. Come on.
She invited you over
to the house.